[Musique]
et je reviens de sites peu en fait le
premier ministre n'a pas répondu
précisément la question ont consisté à
redéfinir la place de la france dans le
pratique et innovant de rassurer les
alliés niçois australiens américains
japonais si on le fait que la france est
une puissance
pacifique ouest néanmoins ce que je
retiens c'est que pour la première fois
je pense projet nice a été clair en
disant qu'il souhaitait et que là que la
nouvelle calédonie reste dans un sens
c'est ce que nous attendions depuis
longtemps malheureusement si ça avait
été plus tôt peut-être que ça et
rassurez-vous couronneries en nouvelle
calédonie et puis et puis bien sûr dans
dans le pacifique et puis ce que je vais
aussi veulent affirmer c'est que sont
irrités nationale alors que l'épidémie
de l'aco vide a frappé la droite est
unie depuis 2006 plan solidarité
nationale joue à plat et ce que je pense
que ils s'en remettent aux intérêts très
reconnaissant
c'est bien pour moi 10 la situation
économique
n'est pas bonne
évidemment les acteurs économiques
s'interrogent beaucoup sucre conséquence
sur le résultat du référendum mais
surtout depuis vingt-huit sanitaires
aussi frappé leur ennemie subit
finalement
double peine quand on est un homme
politique
ce qui est essentiel avant tout c'est de
penser à sa population
et cette population fait ce que soit son
choix d'avenir
souhaite que le plus rapidement possible
cette séquence soit terminé dès qu'on
passe à autre chose et c'est autre chose
c'est qu'en simple puisqu'on construire
un avenir commun de p2i dans lequel
chacune de nos cotisations se retrouvera
et que c'est à dire comment se construit
dans la france
[Musique]